han pasado cuatro años desde que se
suspendió el acuerdo lln de hoy es el
mismo con el que negoció el gobierno de
juan manuel santos
no no es un vélez n en primer lugar
mucho más fuerte ha crecido el tamaño de
su presencia territorial que ha llenado
algunos de los vacíos que dejó
precisamente las farc cuando se
desmovilizaron
y tiene hoy pues también una realidad
cada vez más
evidente de un carácter binacional en la
cual parte de su estructura se encuentra
en venezuela de tal manera que estamos
hablando de un adn muy distinto que
ya vamos a hablar de venezuela
precisamente y es que tanto el n como el
gobierno de gustavo petro habían
reiterado en varias ocasiones su
voluntad de diálogo porque esta vez sí
podría concretarse un acuerdo entre
ambas partes
yo creo que hay varias razones en primer
lugar porque el proceso no arranca de
cero no se logró avanzar como nunca
antes con el nn se llevó a acuerdos
sobre la agenda de negociación se hizo
de hecho un cese al fuego bilateral de
100 días que fue exitoso se ha avanzado
en algunos aspectos que tienen que ver
con la participación de la sociedad y
por lo tanto no se trata de empezar de
nuevo sino retomar lo que venía de
tiempo atrás y por otro lado que se
trate de un gobierno reformista de
izquierda que por primeras en colombia
adelanta muchas de las reformas que
inclusive el propio lm había pedido e
históricamente entonces creo que se
encontró encontramos una situación que
no va a ser fácil no va a ser un proceso
rápido pero sí creo que hay elementos
positivos para pensar que en esta
ocasión se puede abrir una posibilidad
real de llegar a cuerpo